Let's start with the high level.
overview of computer organization
first that's established two words
two terms program and process.
Programmer process we said that a program is the
file in which you write your algorithms.
and when you run the program
you enter to a process, okay?
So at the very top we have your program right the
files that you have written your python files your C++ files
your Java files, right?
and at the very bottom we have the
the hardware the the circuits right
the gates you put
your SSD disk your RAM your CPU
and the way this is going to happen. Is that your program?
Let me actually jump to the next slide to show you something.
Okay, so we'll go back and forth.
So a program is
a file with a let's say C++ extension
python extension or JavaScript extension.
And the way we get to the hardware is through the well the
compiler right which the compiler will convert your
high level programming language.
To ultimately a lower level programmable language. So if
you are programming a C++ you have
the new compiler.
For python it will be the python interpreter.
And I'll come to how you can install this in a moment for JavaScript.
There is no GS. So every poem language will
have its own compiler.
Then we have the assembler the assembler will
convert the high level programmable language to what we
call machine code.
Okay, so the assembler will convert
your high-level point of language to something the operating
system understands.
And then the operating system will interact with the hardware
through something called instruction set architecture.
Okay.
And then there's a tiny layer of software called microcode which
But ultimately will get to ones and zeros,
which translate to electric vehicles to the hardware.
We are going to be focused.
and on the topmost layer
Now I will have some additional material. We won't
cover the live session. We'll go into a
little more detail about these but mainly we will start stay
at this at this level.
Okay.
But there's a little more.
The main program language for this course will be python.
But the I will have a few comments or a
few.
PDF files that also show you
examples in c++?
The purpose is for us to understand what your
program is doing to the computer's memory. Okay?
The purpose is to understand how your program language works
with computer memory. So if I can just skip to this
slide in a moment every single computer.
Every single computer has three components.
when I say computer, I mean from your laptop to the
servers in data centers your
smartphone anything on which any kind of electronic device
on which you run an operating system. That's what I call the computer
and all computers have three components.
They have a processing unit. That's your CPU or
GPU and in the case of machine learning, you know,
we have something like a TPU is a custom-made processing units
for working with large tabular data,
but they're processing units.
And then we have two forms of storage. There's permanent storage and temporary
storage permanent storage, of course is a device that
retains data, even when
the computer is turned off. So SSD disks Optical drives
USB sticks even tape
drives right and temporary storage.
As the name suggests is a storage device.
That will retain data so long as the computer is running.
Has programmers this is our primary concern.
now if your data engineer, you may also want to know how
data is cached on permanent storage, but that's a discussion for later.
Okay, this may be relevant if you're working with big data or if
you're working with yeah if you're working with big data, you know doing things like
mapreduce
But as a programmer, you must be familiar with temporary
storage. So what you program is doing when when
you run it, what is it doing temporary storage?
Okay.